tiempo para la información económica
aquí en directo América de France 24
para eso está con nosotros nuestro
compañero Jorge Hurtado especialista en
la materia Jorge comenzamos en Estados
Unidos con una iniciativa millonaria que
suma para financiar redes de hidrógeno
limpio hablamos Juan de unos siete mil
millones de dólares para utilizar
energía limpia en ese país según la Casa
Blanca la medida se produce para ayudar
a las comunidades a que se den cuenta
los beneficios del hidrógeno limpio y
alcanzar el objetivo de ser una economía
neta de carbono cero para el año 2050 el
hidrógeno puede actualmente puede ser
utilizado como combustible y puede
producirse por medio de fuentes de
energía como la eólica la solar o la
nuclear y también mediante gas natural
la lucha contra el cambio climático es
una de las cuatro prioridades que se
propuso el presidente Joe biden al
llegar a la casa blanca pero la crisis
energética derivada por la guerra en
Ucrania aceleró estos esfuerzos para
buscar fuentes de energía alternativas y
suplir el mercado local y el
Internacional seguimos hablando de esta
crisis energética porque Alemania dice
que el encarecimiento del gas puede
terminar en una pérdida del 2% del
producto interno bruto lo dijo el
ministro de economía alemán Robert
jabeck según él este año la economía
alemana perderá 60.000 millones de euros
invertidos en compras de energía de otra
Fuentes tras en los cortes del
suministro de parte de Rusia para el
próximo año la cifra podría inclusive
ascender a 100 millones de euros dijo a
ver en un congreso de la Federación de
la industria alemana este y el próximo
año Alemania perderá dos puntos
porcentuales del producto interno bruto
cuya falta será notar en todos los
ámbitos de la economía mientras que la
inflación prevén que seguirá creciendo
en 2023 en abril gas prom germania fue
intervenida por el gobierno alemán y
recibió un crédito de más de 9.000
millones de euros precisamente para
protegerla del insolvencia Aunque
algunos medios locales revelan que esa
cifra probablemente fue insuficiente
vamos surge de nuevo a Estados Unidos
porque hay un estudio que nos va a
ayudar a comprender Cuál es el peso de
los latinoamericanos en la economía de
Estados Unidos si los latinos en Estados
Unidos fuesen un país independiente su
aporte económico sería el octavo más
grande en el mundo después de Estados
Unidos china Japón o Alemania el
producto interno bruto de esta comunidad
en Estados Unidos Fue de 2,8 billones de
dólares en 2020 según el informe de
latitud los latinos que son casi el 19%
de la población de Estados Unidos
aportan más que economías como Italia o
Brasil el estudio también muestra que
entre el año 2010 y el 2020 el producto
interno bruto de los latinos en Estados
Unidos Fue el tercero de crecimiento más
rápido entre los 10 mayores del mundo
incluso 21% más rápido que el de la
India y 30% más rápido que china en ese
periodo de la actividad económica de los
hispanos tuvo un ritmo de 2,6 veces más
alto que el de la población no latina en
ese país en 2020 el aporte latino
representó el 16,6% de la actividad
total del país en finanzas seguros y
bienes raíces el 13% de los servicios
profesionales el 13,3% un servicio
gubernamentales y el 8,4% en educación
cuidado de la salud y asistencia social
los investigadores también revelan un
dato importante resaltan en el estudio
las virtudes que tienen los latinos como
la resiliencia tras la pandemia en la
autosuficiencia y el optimismo unos
datos de la comunidad latina Jorge por
su parte el gigante va a tener que pagar
200 millones de dólares por las
acusaciones que le hace la comisión de
valores de Estados Unidos la empresa fue
acusada de engaño a los inversores sobre
su 737 Max que estuvo en tierra durante
20 meses después de dos accidentes
mortales la compañía dijo que voy y su
director No admitieron ni negaron las
conclusiones de la agencia regular
reguladora de Estados Unidos anunciaron
que se creará un fondo de beneficio de
los inversores perjudicados voy también
dijo que había hecho cambios
fundamentales que han fortalecido los
procesos de seguridad y que el acuerdo
es parte del esfuerzo de compañía Para
sanar responsabilidades de estos asuntos
legales que estaban pendientes los
accidentes estaban relacionados con un
sistema de control de vuelo denominado
sistema de aumento de las
características de maniobra en enero del
año 2021 voy a acordó pagar $2,500
millones de dólares en multas e
indemnizaciones para resolver una
investigación penal del departamento de
justicia de Estados Unidos hablamos de
arte porque Damián hirs presentó una
exposición y después la va a pasar a un
formato digital para un token no
fungible Así es la exposición se llama
the currency es el primer proyecto de
Gears con el nft o toque no fungible una
nueva tecnología cada vez más popular
como forma de poseer arte los nft son
como un certificado digital de
autenticidad que usa la tecnología
blockchain precisamente la misma que
usan las criptomonedas y se asocia a un
único archivo digital para transferirse
el proyecto cuenta con 10.000 piezas que
salieron a la venta por 2000 dólares
cada una las pinturas con puntos
multicolores estaba por el autor todas
con su respectivo en este una de ellas
fue vendida por 172 mil dólares el
artista dijo que quemará alguna de las
obras el 11 de octubre pues ahora la
mayoría serán digitales el arte y el
mundo digital combinados Jorge Hurtado
con la información económica Muchísimas
gracias Gracias también ustedes
continuamos aquí en directo América de
Francia 24
[Música]